vous avez un smartphone de Samsung et
vous voulez apprendre plein de trucs et
d'astuces pour mieux l'utiliser au
quotidien mais vous êtes au bon endroit
on va se regarder aujourd'hui des
astuces des nouveautés plein de choses
super bien qu'on peut bien faire avec
son smartphone de Samsung vous êtes
prévu vous êtes prêt allez on y va
moi ici je suis sur un Galaxy S23 ultra
je me baser là-dessus j'ai la dernière
version one US 5.1 donc il se peut que
si vous n'avez pas tout de suite la 5.1
et bien il se peut que quelques
fonctionnalités que vous ne verrez pas
mais dès lors vous aurez la mise à jour
vous aurez absolument tout tout et
absolument tout allez on y va pas trop
de temps la première fonctionnalité
c'est un truc qui vachement important
parce que si vous devez emmener vos
smartphones à se faire réparer dans un
magasin à droite à gauche et bien le
réparateur vous demandera les mots de
passe il aura accès absolument
absolument à toute votre vie vos
contacts vos photos même les photos les
plus sensibles bref tout donc il y a un
mode que Samsung est venu mettre en
place et qui est vraiment vraiment bien
c'est le mode maintenant ce qui fera
qu'effectivement la personne qui vient
faire une maintenance en votre
smartphone n'aura plus accès à rien pour
ce faire et bien vous allez dans vos
paramètres vous allez sur batterie et
maintenant de pareil vous voyez c'est
juste ici et vous cliquez là et là juste
en bas vous allez avoir le fameux mode
Maintenance vous cliquez ici et là il
vous explique le mode maintenance
protège votre confidentialité lorsqu'une
autre personne utilise votre téléphone
par exemple lorsque vous l'envoyez en
réparation et bien regardez vous cliquez
ici et vous l'activez il doit redémarrer
ça me crée un petit journal et ça
démarre mon smartphone là il vous le
marque ça bascule en mode maintenant
basculement en mode maintenant le
téléphone est en train de démarrer et
donc la personne qui va récupérer votre
téléphone regardez ça vous le marque
bien en bas mode maintenant et donc ici
ça veut dire qu'on a plus accès à vos
photos par exemple je vais dans Google
photos mais voyez j'ai plus accès à
Google photos j'ai ma galerie mais dans
ma galerie je n'ai absolument rien du
tout j'ai pas mes autres applications
j'ai juste un truc de base mes
applications de base et je peux pas
faire plus que ça et une fois que c'est
fini qu'est-ce que je fais et bien
claque je reviens ici je retourne dans
batterie et maintenant de l'appareil
mode maintenant et je quitte le mode
maintenant je redémarre le téléphone et
là on me demande quoi on me demande de
confirmer mon identité soit avec un mot
de passe soit avec le schéma soit avec
mon empreinte digitale pour certifier
que c'est bien moi et auquel cas le mode
maintenance va être désactivé je vais
tout récupérer tous mes accès donc ça
c'est vachement bien et je trouve ça une
fois de plus extrêmement sécurisant
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que ça vous est déjà arrivé de laisser
votre smartphone même un ordinateur
pourquoi pas tout votre vie privée à
l'intérieur et vous dire j'espère que la
personne qui va s'occuper de la
réparation n'a pas regardé mes photos
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires
puisqu'on parle de la batterie mais il y
a une optimisation au niveau de la
batterie qui est vachement cool vous
venez toujours
un batterie et maintenant de l'appareil
vous cliquez là et là vous allez pouvoir
venir vérifier votre batterie vérifier
que tout va bien et l'optimiser donc
vous cliquez si vous optimisez ça fait
un tour de tout le bousin et ça c'est
très très bien vous pouvez même le faire
de façon automatique c'est ce que je
vous recommande vous allez sur
optimisation automatique vous venez
cocher ça redémarrage en cas de besoin
si besoin ça redémarrera votre téléphone
mais au moins vous êtes totalement
optimisé ça c'est très très bien autre
astuce qui est très cool qu'on avait sur
iOS qu'on avait pas ici sur Manuel et
bien regardez vous venez dans votre
galerie vous allez prendre n'importe
quelle photo je vais prendre une photo
de moi tenez par exemple hop là hop
cette photo de moi ça c'est pris avec le
mode portrait et bien regardez je n'ai
qu'à appuyer ici ça va me reconnaître ça
va faire le tour de mon personnage et
voyez je l'ai ici alors grosse
différence que vous avez c'est que sur
iOS bah regardez vous pouvez venir
sortir de votre application directement
et le poser dans une note le copier dans
un message ici vous pouvez pas Samsung
ne va pas aussi loin par contre ce que
vous pouvez faire c'est propose de le
copier de le partager ou de
l'enregistrer comme image donc je peux
l'enregistrer comme image et là je vais
la retrouver directement dans mes photos
et bien tout en haut tout seul ici me
voilà moi détourer donc ça c'est quand
même vachement pratique mais au-delà de
ça vous pouvez laisser votre doigt
appuyer vous pouvez la partager vous
pouvez la copier donc vous la copiez et
si vous voulez la mettre sur une note et
bien vous allez ici vous allez dans
Samsung note je viens ici et là je
laisse mon doigt appuyer et je peux le
coller et après je peux venir le
redimensionner je peux venir le déplacer
le mettre comme si et comme ça donc ça
c'est assez marrant on connaissait déjà
un peu l'histoire mais on peut faire
encore mieux que ça donc là je suis moi
par exemple comme ça mais je peux venir
mettre une autre image alors ça tombe
plutôt bien parce que regarder la bonne
nouvelle c'est que je suis venu et que
j'ai photographié la lune l'autre jour
donc là par exemple on a la lune on veut
faire quoi on va faire exactement la
même chose ça vient reconnaître la lune
je copie la lune je reviens dans mon
application et là je viens coller la
Lune et du coup je peux venir mettre ma
lune ici donc bon la seule truc que
j'aurais bien aimé c'est pouvoir venir
déplacer ma lune qui est là et la mettre
là mais là je peux pas oui ça c'est un
peu la limite aussi de l'application
donc je peux faire pas mal de petites
choses donc si je veux faire un petit
exposé bien sûr la lune et ben regardez
là j'ai une photo que j'ai été prendre
de la lune directement avec mon galaxy
S23 ultra qui est très cool d'ailleurs
j'avais fait une vidéo je vous montre
les premières images faites avec le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra je vous mets le
lien dans la description les jeter un
coup d'oeil puis bien évidemment c'est
smartphone Galaxy S2 3S 23 plus S23
ultra sont disponibles sur le store de
Samsung et une fois de plus je vous mets
le lien en bas dans la description la
quatrième astuce c'est pour vous montrer
un nouveau widget qui vient d'arriver
qui est vachement bien
et bien qui est dans vos widgets vous
venez le chercher vous avez un widget
batterie il y a deux façons d'avoir
votre widget de batterie soit comme ça
en cas de parent hop la 4 colonnes par
une soit en 4 par 2 on va le prendre en
4 par 1 je clique j'ajoute il arrive là
et là il est super chouette pourquoi
parce que j'ai retrouvé niveau de
batterie de tous mes appareils connectés
alors là j'ai uniquement mon smartphone
mais si vous avez des Galaxy buds vous
les aurez si vous avez une galaxie watch
vous l'aurez si vous avez différents
appareils Galaxy dans l'écosystème il y
a vous les aurez ici ça c'est très très
chouette ça c'est le premier truc et je
trouve ça pas mal fichu et plutôt malin
donc ça c'est chouette ça me plaît bien
et on peut aller beaucoup plus loin
parce que ça me saoule nous a proposé un
truc qui est très malin c'est l'idée de
mettre plusieurs widgets au même endroit
là donc j'ai ce widget là hop vous venez
vous choisissez vos widgets et on va
venir se choisir des widgets qui sont en
même dimension en cas de par un donc
batterie je l'ai déjà mis bien-être
numérique Bixby vision en cas de par un
hop j'ajoute je peux avoir un autre
widget de la recherche avec Rome ici
vous voyez ou bien encore un dernier mon
horloge ici donc là ou normalement je
viens démultiplier les widgets et c'est
relativement pas terrible et bien
regardez là je prends mon widget et je
n'ai qu'à les mettre tous au même
endroit il faut qu'il fasse détails là
c'est du 4 par 1 c'est pour ça que ça
intéressant et une fois que j'ai fini
bien regarder je n'ai qu'à venir tourner
ici comme ça mais widget sont
complètement incorporés de la même
manière j'ai pas toujours le gros fond
vous voyez le gros fond hop il diminue
et j'ai tous mes widgets sous la main ça
c'est vachement bien parce que une fois
de plus ça vous évite d'avoir 15 widgets
au même endroit alors il faut savoir que
vous avez les autres widgets mais il y a
une petite barre qui vous l'indique là
c'est mon niveau de batterie si j'ai
plus besoin de ça et bien je viens là et
je trouve ça extrêmement malin autre
astuce qui est géniale au niveau de
votre smartphone Samsung et bien vous
avez différents modes de disponible par
exemple vous allez dire et bien je me
mets en mode sommeil lorsque je me
reposais ça va donc vouloir dire et bien
à ce moment-là ne venez pas me déranger
je coupe les notifications je coupe les
appels je suis en mode travail et bien
je vais couper toutes les notifications
je suis en mode détente je vais couper
aussi les notifs je vais couper les
appels bref je vais choisir il y a un
autre truc qui permet d'aller vachement
plus loin c'est-à-dire vous allez
pouvoir venir personnaliser votre fond
d'écran en fonction de ce que vous
faites par exemple je vous montre ce que
j'ai défini moi sur le mode exercice et
bien ça m'active le mode exercice et ça
me change mon fond d'écran ça me met un
fond d'écran plus lié au sport je m'en
suis mis un autre par exemple par
rapport au mode cinéma et bien voyez je
passe en mode cinéma là ça me met un
fond d'écran lié au mode cinéma je
trouve ça vachement bien parce qu'on
pouvait venir tout personnaliser ici et
même l'expérience globale au niveau du
fond d'écran ça me plaît beaucoup
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez vous est-ce que ça vous plaît oui
ou non marquez moi ça dans les
commentaires autre astuce si vous voulez
avoir un écran lorsque comme ça vous
arrivez qui est complètement épuré pas
d'horloge et bien c'est possible là où
ça l'était pas avant je vous montre
comment il faut faire j'ai juste mis le
nom de mon smartphone en bas Galaxy S23
ultra de Monsieur gauche complètement
venu personnalisé à l'expérience donc
j'ai plus qu'à venir déverrouiller et en
fonction de mon fond d'écran ça va me
donner l'espace encore plus personnalisé
ça c'est très très chouette ce que vous
faites c'est que vous laissez appuyer
directement sur votre Smartphone vous
allez dans fond d'écran et style et vous
cliquez ici sur votre écran d'accueil
ici voilà juste là et là normalement
vous avez une horloge une horloge qui
est ici il y a différents styles
d'horloge c'est joli il y en a pour tous
les goûts et là vous allez même l'option
aucune horloge et c'est ça que j'ai fait
donc c'est fait vous voyez que je ne me
retrouve avec absolument aucune horloge
j'ai également pareil supprimer les
notifications qu'on retrouve ici
icône uniquement détails moi j'en ai mis
aucune et je suis venu personnaliser ici
le petit module en bas vous n'avez
appuyer dessus et vous venez taper le
message que vous voulez très simplement
ensuite vous cliquez sur Terminer ça
enregistre et lorsque vous éteignez
votre téléphone et que vous le rallumez
et bien ça fait place net c'est propre
c'est neuf il y a rien c'est très
chouette merci à vous puisque je vous
parlais de widget il y en a un autre qui
est tout nouveau et que je trouve
vachement bien ça c'est one uye 5.1 et
bien c'est le widget météo qui a été
revu corrigé plus dynamique plus jolie
regardez faites un appui long vous allez
ici dans vos widgets alors ça je vous le
recommande parce que je trouve beaucoup
mieux que ce qu'il y avait avant avant
c'était bien mais c'était un peu
tristounet c'est ça là c'est la météo
dynamique car vous êtes toujours la
météo un peu classique qui est un peu
moins bonne la météo dynamique est cool
vous en avez d'autres et qui sont un peu
moins rigolotes vous allez sur la météo
dynamique vous l'ajoutez la regarder
tout de suite c'est dynamique c'est beau
ça bouge ça va donner un peu de vie en
fonction de là où vous êtes en fonction
de la météo puis vous cliquez dessus
c'est pareil c'est tout de suite
beaucoup plus dynamique c'est chouette
donc ça je trouve ça très très bien et
une fois de plus et une nouveauté qu'on
vient retrouver ici donc changez moi
c'est widget un peu ancien il y a un
petit peu moche mettez le widget avec la
météo dynamique et ça va donner un peu
plus de peps à votre smartphone autre
astuce qui est très cool c'est au niveau
de la photographie dans l'application
Photos avant lorsque que vous voulez
utiliser le mode Expert rose une
application en plus qu'il fallait venir
télécharger Samsung est venu l'inclure
directement dans son smartphone donc
vous allez ici dans plus et vous allez
retrouver tout en haut à gauche alors il
faut cliquer dessus ça vous le
télécharge et ensuite ici vous allez
pouvoir aller beaucoup plus loin au
niveau de vos photos en mode RAW avec un
histogramme avec plein de possibilités
vous venez tout changer directement vous
venez tout moduler ici alors s'adresse
plus aux personnes qui sont des amoureux
de la photographie et qui veulent venir
être dans un mode manuel qui veulent
débrayer manuellement directement ici
avec notamment comme je l'ai là mon
samsung galaxy S23 ultra mais vous
pourrez le faire également avec tous les
smartphones qui sont basés sur One ui
5.1 et puisque je vous parle de
l'application Photos il y a aussi une
nouveauté qui a été apportée une
correction de l'amélioration au niveau
de la photo lorsque vous passez en
caméra de selfie et bien ils sont venus
vous mettre juste en haut à droite
regardez juste ici l'icône avec les
filtres qu'on avait pas ici avant donc
c'est beaucoup plus facile beaucoup plus
simple donc ça il faut le savoir si vous
aimiez les filtres et que vous les
utilisiez pas et bien vous pouvez venir
les retrouver ici beaucoup plus
facilement je trouve ça assez marrant
alors moi je suis pas un très gros
client de filtre mais il y en a qui le
énormément c'est donc si tu es
maintenant juste là vous l'activer vous
le désactiver vous choisissez faites ce
que vous voulez bref c'est très pratique
voilà pour ces 10 astuces 10 nouveautés
qu'on va retrouver ici sur son
smartphone de Samsung bah c'est bien
évidemment avec pas mal de nouveautés
sur One ui 5.1 la dernière version qui
pour l'instant disponible uniquement sur
les Samsung Galaxy S23 mais qui va bien
évidemment s'étendre à l'ensemble de la
gamme donc vous l'aurez très
prochainement si c'est pas déjà le cas
est-ce que vous connaissiez une de ces
astuces est-ce que vous attendiez une en
particulier est-ce que ça vous intéresse
marquez moi ça dans les commentaires et
puis nous on se retrouve bientôt avec
d'autres astuces de Samsung d'ailleurs
dites-moi si vous voyez plein d'astuces
comme ça je vous parle d'astuces sur
Samsung d'astuces sur Apple pourquoi pas
sur iOS d'astuces pour Mew de Xiaomi
d'astuces pour coloros de repos
d'astuces pour oxygénos de oneplus bref
marquez moi ça dans les commentaires et
nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler tech je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao ciao
[Musique]